Dewa, daisanka no kanji.
Ee, daisanka no kanji wa korera no juukyuu
no kanji wo shoukai shimasu.
Mazu saishou no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa other to
iu imi ga arimasu.
Sore de desu ne, ee kochira no part, minna
mo yoku shittemasu yo ne, kore, person no
imi desu.
Ee sorekara kono migi gawa nandesu keredomo,
kore ma it looks like ya and in fact this
actually is pronounced as ya and when Japanese
people kind of you know meet other
people or other person, we say ya, genki?
So it means other.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de
ta.
Kunyomi wa arimasen.
Ee, de tatoeba, tannin.
Kore, stranger, ma other people de mo daijoubu
desu kedo.
Sorekara, haitatekina.
Chotto muzukashii kotoba desu keredomo, exclusive.
Sorekara, sonota, kore etc.
Sonota nani ka hitsumon ga arimasu ka?
Do you have any other questions?
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Dewa tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa both
no imi ga arimasu.
De, ma oboekata nan desu keredomo, a scale
with both sides in balance.
Nani ka ko, mukashi na scale ga atte, de,
scale both sides in balance, ma konna oboekata
ga ii kamo shiremasen.
De yomikata nandseukeredo mo, onyomi de ryou
to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Ee, kono kanji kunyomi wa arimasen.
De, tatoeba, ryoushin, kore wa both no imi
ga arimasu.
De kore wa oya, parent, parents desu kara,
so parents.
Ryougawa, both sides.
Sorekara ryoute, both hands to iu imi desu.
De, chotto tsukaikata ga ano, nandesuka, chigau
desu keredomo, kore, ryougae suru, kore, money
exchange no toki ni tsukaimasu.
Tatoeba, en wo doru (dollar) ni ryougae suru
tte iu.
Okane no exchange no toki ni ryougae to iu
kotoba wo tsukaimasu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi wa present,
sorekara hit no imi ga arimasu.
Ee, kono paato (part) ma imagine the shape
of hands and then some arrow just hit your
hand to iu no de, ma hit to iu imi desu.
Ee yomikata nan desu keredomo, ee onyomi de
tou, tatoeba toujitsu, that very day.
Touji, at that time.
Sorekara, hontou, truth.
Hontou desu ka to iu yoku tsukaimasu ne.
Ato, obento, kono, kono tou wo tsukaimasu,
bentou.
Sorekara, tousensuru, to be elected to iu
tsukaikata desu.
Kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, ataru to
iu no de, tatoeba takarakuji ni ataru.
Win the lottery, takarakuji ni atarimashita
to iu, koko particle wa ni desu.
Kiotsukete kudasai.
Sorekara, hiatari, ano ma eigo de wa exposure
to the sun nan desu keredomo, hiatari ga ii
heiya to iu tsukaikata wo yoku shimasu.
Ato, atarimae, usual, natural.
Nihonjin ga yoku iu koto de, sonna koto atarimae
koto da, that’s natural, nothing special
toka, sonna tsukaikata desu.
Ato, teate suru, to provide medical care,
konna tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Hai tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa help,
rescue sorekara assistance no imi ga arimasu.
Ma, oboekata nan desu keredomo, so this part,
the alter gives strength, kore wa strength,
chikara desu yo no, to those who seek help,
to iu ma, konna oboekata ga ii ka to omoimasu.
De eeto, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi
de jo.
Tatoeba, joshi, particle desu yo ne.
Sorede joshu, assistant.
Jokyouju, kyouju to iu no ga professor desu.
So jokyouju means assistant professor.
Jyokantoku, kantoku tte iu no wa movie director
no koto desu.
So jokantoku, assistant director.
Sorekara jogensuru, to advise.
Enjosuru, to aid or to support.
Sorekara, kyuujosuru, to rescue.
Kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, ee, kore
tasukeru, kore wa transitive verb desu.
Nani nani wo tasukeru.
Tatoeba, boku no tomodachi wo tasukete kudasai.
Ee, sorekara, tasukaru, kore wa to be safe,
intransitive desu.
Anata no okagede, aruiwa sensei no okagede,
ryoushin to okage de, hontoni tasukarimashita,
I was saved.
Konna tsukaikata desu.
Hai. tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji nan desu keredomo, imi wa voice
no imi ga arimasu.
De, eeto ma oboekata nandesukeredo mo, kono
ue no part, this part actually indicates soldier.
So soldier with weapon, this part, shouting
with a double loud mouth, two mouth, and so
it means voice.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de
sei, to iu no yoku tsukaimasu.
Tatoeba, onsei, kore, voice, sound.
Sorekara mensei to iu no de, fame to iu imi
ga arimasu.
Ato, giseigo, onomatopoeia, konna yomikata
ga, kore, yosu ni, oto, maneru to iu no de,
onomatopoeia desu.
Kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, ee.
koe to iu no ga omona tsukata desu.
Kowa to mo yomu toki ga arun desu keredomo,
minna wa koe dake de daijoubu desu.
Koe, voice.
Sorekara, oogoe, ooki na koe to iu imi nan
desu keredomo, tatoeba, oogoe de hanasanai
de kudasai.
Kokode wa oogoe dewa hanasanai de kudasai.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa offer
toka, accompany no imi ga arimasu.
De, kono paato (part) mo minna yoku shitteimasu
ne, person.
Ee, soshite, kochira no paato (part) nan desu
keredomo, imi wa together no imi ga arimasu.
So the person who comes together to accompany
no imi desu.
De yomikata nan desu keredomo, ee onyomi de
kyou toka ku to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, teikyousuru, kore, to offer.
Sorekara, kyoukyuusuru, kore to supply.
Ato desu ne kore wa bukkyou ano bai ni yoku
tsukaun desu keredomo, kuyou suru, to hold
service for the deceased.
Chotto ano Buddhism no kankei no kotoba desu.
Onyomi no, aa sumimasen.
Kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, sonaeru
toka tomo to iu, ano yoku tsukawareru no wa
kore desu ne, kodomo, children or child.
Hantai wa kore otona desu.
Sorekara otomosuru to iu no de, to accompany.
Sorekara sonaeru, kore ga mata bukkyou no
ano, kotoba de yoku tsukawarerun desu keredomo,
to offer.
Tatoeba, hotokesama ni hana wo sonaeru, offering
flowers to the Buddha toka.
Kore mo matta kuyou suru to onaji you ni,
chotto bukkyou to kankei no kotoba desu.
Hai tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi wa call
toka, invite to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, kono part, hidari gawa no paato (part)
desu ne, kore wa mouth.
Soshite, this part it’s not exactly the
same as the hand, but imagine this looks like
hand.
So with hand and mouth, someone is calling
you or inviting you.
De onyomi nan desu keredomo, kore ko to yomimasu.
Tatoeba, kokyuu suru, to breathe.
Sorekara, koousuru, to respond to iu tsukaikata
ga arimasu.
De kunyomi no yo nan desu keredomo, yobu.
Kono doushi wa desu ne context ni yotte iroiro
na imi ga chigaimasu.
Kiotsukete kudasai.
Tatoeba, kore wa nani nani to yobarete imasu.
Konna toki ni wa it is called, it is nandesuka,
call such and such to iu tsukaikata desu.
Sorekara namae wo yonde kudasai.
Kore wa call out your name.
Sorekara party ni yobarete imasu.
Kono toki ni wa invite no imi ga arimasu.
Kiotsukete kudasai.
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi wa suffering,
bitter, sorekara painful to iu imi nan desu keredomo,
kono ue no part, kore wa daijoubu
desu ne.
Kore imi wa grass no imi desu.
Tatoeba, kore kusuri desu keredomo, so a grass
that makes you feel comfortable or
funny, kore ga kusuri desu yo ne.
De, shita no part, kore furui, old.
So when you eat some old grass, it suffers,
or bitter or it becomes painful to iu imi desu.
De, onyomi nan desu keredomo, ku to iu yomikata
ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, kurou suru, to suffer.
Sorekara, kutsuu, pain.
Sorekara kujou, kore wa complain desu.
Kunyomi nan desu keredomo, kuru, sorekara,
niga to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, kurushii, i adjective desu.
Kore painful.
Sorekara nigai, kochira wa bitter no imi desu.
Kore wa chotto nigai desu ne, this is bitter,
to iu, ano, taste no bitter desu.
Sorekara nigate, kore wa na adjective nan
desu keredomo, poor at no imi ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, sports ga nigate desu.
Particle, joshi, ga desu no de kiotsukete
kudasai, I’m poor at sports.
Kono hantai ga tokui, be good at to iu kotoba
ga arimasu.
Kore mo sports ga tokui desu, joshi ga ga
desu.
Ato, tatoeba nigate na kamoku subject wa suugaku
desu, mathematics.
Sou desu ne, kore na adjective desu no de
kiotsukete kudasai.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa law toka,
method no imi ga arimasu.
De, kono paato (part) desu keredomo, kore
daijoubu yo desu ne, water no imi desu.
So sorekara desu ne kono migi gawa kore, eeto,
saru, leaving, to iu imi ga arimasu.
So water leaving a reservoir to irrigate the
rice field systematically.
So, nanika, law, method to iu imi ga arimasu.
De yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de hou
toka hatsu, hotsu to iu yomikata ga arun desu ga,
tatoeba housoku, kore wa principle toka
theorem.
Houritsu, kore wa, ano, law, legal no law
desu.
Sorekara, bunpou, kore daijoubu desu ne, grammar,
nihongo no bunpou ga muzukashii desu.
Sorekara, houhou, method.
Sorekara, kenpou, kore constitution.
Konna tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa cry no
imi desu.
De, mo kochira no ano hidari no radical, kore
daijoubu desu yo ne, kore water no imi desu.
Ee, sorekara, kono migi gawa, kono bubun,
kore standing.
So person is standing and you see the water
dropping, he is crying.
De, eeto onyomi nan desu keredomo, kyuu, kore
amari tsukawanain desu keredomo, ma hitsu
tatoeba, goukyuu suru to iu, to wail nandesu
ga, totemo naku to iu imi desu.
Amari tsukaimasen.
Kunyomi no hou naku.
Ee, tatoeba, akachan ga naite imasu.
Sorekara, nakigoe, kore, crying voice.
Ato, tokidoki tsukau no ga, nakigao, naiteiru
kao to iu imi desu, face.
Ee, sore ni taishite, tatoeba, waraigao, waratteiru
kao, konna kotoba mo imasu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa thought,
desire, attention no imi ga arimasu.
De, ee, kono ue no part, kore, ima desu yo
ne, now, sorekara, moment to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, shita no part, kore minna mo yoku shitteru
to omoun desu keredomo, heart toka feelings
no imi ga arimasu.
So the current feeling to iu no de, ma thought,
desire, attention to iu imi ni narimasu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, kunyomi wa
nain desu ga, onyomi de nen to yomimasu.
Tatoeba, zannen na, unfortunate, disappointing,
na adjective desu.
Sorekara, gainen, kore concept.
Ato, kinenbi, kinenn suru to iu no de, to
celebrate toka, kinenbi no toki ni wa anniversary.
Yoku tsukau no ga kekkon kinenbi, wedding
anniversary to iu kotoba ga arimasu.
Ato, sennensuru to iu no de, to concentrate.
Ee, tatoeba, nihongo no benkyou ni sennen
shimasu.
Ee, joshi, particle wa ni desuno de, kiotsukete
kudasai.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa straight,
fix, repair no imi ga arimasu.
De, ma kono kanji no oboekata nan desu keredomo,
ma it takes ten, koko jyuu desu yo ne, ten
pairs of eyes, kore ga eyes, to fix a corner
not made at a right angle.
Ma konna oboekata de ii kamo, shiremasen.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, eeto choku, jiki,
jika to iu yomikata ga arun desuga, tatoeba
cho- ee, kore chokusetsu, direct.
Watashi ni chokusetsu renraku shite kudasai,
contact me directly.
Sorekara, chokugo, ma immediately following,
right after.
Sorekara, chokuzen, kore just before.
Yoku, ee, hikouki nanka de, chokkoubin, kore
wa direct nonstop flight no koto desu.
Tatoeba, boston kara tokyo e no chokkoubin.
Sorekara, shoujiki na, kore na adjective,
honest nan desu kedo,
kare wa shoujiki na hito desu.
He’s an honest person.
Kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, ee mazu
tada toka, nao, dochira
no yomikata ga arun desu keredomo,
transitive intransitive no pair ga arimasu.
Transitive verb no toki, ma, naosu, tadasu
to yomu hito mo imasu.
Ee, demo naosu.
Tatoeba, kuruma wo naoshite kudasai.
Ee, korekara, naoru, kore wa intransitive
desu.
Kuruma ga naorimashita.
Ato desu ne, eeto, verb stem plus nausu to
iu no de, tatoeba, redo something to fix.
Tatoeba, yoku dedekuru no wa kore desu ne,
report wo kakinaoshite kudasai.
Ee, rewrite to fix it, the report.
Sorekara, sono shigoto wo shinaoshite kudasai,
mou ichido ee kono action wo shite,
fix shite kudasai to iu imi desu.
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa single
to iu imi desu.
De, ma eeto, koko no ue no part, kore wa ma
desu ne, imagine like a water, san zui, water
radical.
Bringing water to the fields, kore tanbou
no ta, makes farmers much, ten times like
easier or simpler to iu no de, ma single.
Sorekara, simple to iu imi mo dedekimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de, tatoeba,
kantan na, simple.
Na adjective desu.
Ee, sorekara tango, kore wa vocabulary, word.
Sorekara, tani, kore, unit.
Tatoeba kono class no tani wa jyuuni tani
desu.
Konna tsukaikata ga daijoubu desu.
Sorekara, tanni, merely to iu tsukaikata desu.
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi wa start,
emit no imi ga arimasu.
De, ma oboekata nan desu keredomo, so two
hands removing the gate bolt, here, in order
to leave.
Ee, kono paato (part) leave to iu imi ga aru
mitai desu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de
hatsu toka hotsu to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Ee, tatoeba, hatsuon suru, to pronounce.
Ee yoku iu no ga ano hito no nihongo no hatsuon
wa totemo kirei desu.
Hatsuon, kono toki wa ma pronunciation desu
yo ne.
Sorekara, hatsumei suru, to invent.
Ee, denki, electricity, denki wo hatsumei
shita hito wa dare desu ka.
Sorekara, shuppatsu suru, to depart.
Ee, sono hikouki ha mou tokyo wo shuppatsu
shimashita.
Particle, kore wo desu no de kiotsukete kudasai.
Sorekara, hakken suru, to discover.
Hattatsu suru, ee kore wa intransitive desu.
Tatoeba, robot no gijutsu ga hattatsu shite
imasu, ne.
Sorekara, hatsu netsu, netsu ga deru to iu
no de, fever to iu imi mo arimasu.
Kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, ee, kore
tatsu, to depart.
Ee, particle no hou chotto kiotsukete kudasai.
Mou naritaku kou wo tachimashita.
Depart from ma kore, wo wo tsukaimasu.
Sorekara kyuushu ni tachimashita.
Kore wa depart for to iu tsukaikata desu.
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa head,
neck, leader to iu imi mo arimasu.
Ee de, kono paato (part) desu yo ne, kono
paato (part) wa eeto, self to iu imi ga arimasu
yo ne.
Jibun no ji desu.
So, you need some sort of protection here
to protect your head or to protect your neck
to iu ano, oboekata de ii ka to omoimasu.
De, onyomi nan desu keredomo, kore, shu.
Tatoeba, shuto, kore capital city.
Shushou, prime minister.
Ee sorekara, shui, kore first place.
Sorekara, bushu, kore kanji no radical no
koto desu.
Sorekara, jishu suru, jibun kara dedeiku to
iu no de, surrender.
Ee yoku ma keisatsu ni jishu suru to iu tsukaikata
ga arimasu.
Ato kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, kore
wa kubi.
Ee, kubi daijoubu desu ne, kore wa neck.
Sorekara, tekubi, kono toki wa, wrist no imi
ga arimasu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa link
toka, in succession, group, sonna imi ga arimasu.
De, ee, kono part, kore wa daijoube desu ne,
kore wa cars.
Eem sorekara, kono radical, kore wa road toka
walk, sono imi ga arun desukeredo mo,
you can imagine cars traveling in a row on the
street in succession as a group, sonna fuu
ni oboerareru to omoimasu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de
ren.
Ee tatoeba, renkyuu, kore wa consecutive holidays,
sanrenkyuu nara eeto mikkakan no ano consecutive,
in sequence no yasumi to iu, sanrenkyuu, aruiwa
yonrenkyuu.
Gorenkyuu to iu iikata mo arimasu.
Sorekara, kokuren, kore wa united nations.
Sorekara kanrensuru, kore wa relate, to relate.
Sorekara renraku suru, to contact.
Tatoeba, sensei ni kanarazu renrakushite kudasai.
Ee sorekara kunyomi nan desu keredomo, yomikata
toshite wa tsura toka tsu nandesuga,
hitotsu tsuranaru, kore, to stand in a row.
Tatoeba desu ne, utsukushii yamayama, beautiful
mountains, yama yama ga tsuranatteiru.
Sorekara, tsurete iku, to bring, kore wa to
bring someone no hou desu.
Ee, motte iku, kore wa to bring something.
Kiotsukete kudasai.
Sorekara, konomo tsure to iu iikata mo arimasu,
kore wa accompanied by children.
Yoku sou desu ne nanika announcement nanika
de desu ne, kodomo tsure no hito tachi wa
kuruma ni kiotsukete kudasai.
So for those accompanied by children or those
who have children, kuruma ni kiotsukete kudasai.
Ee, konna iikata mo arimasu.
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa laugh.
Ee, kono ue no part, kore wa ii desu yo ne,
kore wa bamboo.
Ee, sorekara, kore wa ooki desu ne.
So you can say a big bamboo stick, kore wa
stick desu keredomo, a big bamboo stick can
make people laugh.
De, kore de laugh to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de
shou.
Bakushousuru, kore totemo, ma nandesuka, warau
to iu no de, laugh hard.
Sorekara kushou suru, kore smile bitterly.
Kunyomi no hou ga yoku tsukawaremasu.
Ee, tatoeba, warau, to laugh.
Sorekara, waraibanashi, kore funny story.
Ato desu, kono e to iu yomikata mo arimasu.
E, egao, kore, ma, waratteiru egao.
Mae ni chotto benkyou shita kedo, nakigao,
kore wa naiteiru kao to iu imi desu.
Sorekara, kore, hohoemu, kore, to smile to
iu tsukaikata desu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa collect
no imi ga arimasu.
Ee, kono shita no bubun, kore wa ii desu yo
ne,tree.
Sorekara kono ue no bubun nan desu keredomo,
ee, kore wa birds to iu imi ga arimasu.
So a tree is a gathering place for birds.
Konna katachi de oboete mite kudasai.
De yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de shu.
Tatoeba, boshuu suru, kore wa to recruit.
Atarashii sensei wo boshuu shite imasu.
Sorekara, shuuchuu suru, kore wa to concentrate.
Ee, particle kiotsukete kudasai.
Kono shigoto ni shuuchuu shiteimasu.
Benkyou ni shuuchuu shitemasu.
Ni wo tsukaimasu.
Sorekara, henshuu suru, kore wa to edit.
Tatoeba, kono ronbun wo henshuu shite kudasai.
Sorekara, kore wa noun, shudan desu keredomo,
group to iu imi desu.
Ee, yoku ano pandemic no toki ni tsukawareru
kotoba de shudankansen, kore outbreak, group
no kansen, kansen to iu no wa infect, infection
nan desu keredomo, outbreak to iu tsukaikata desu.
Sorekara, kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo,
ee, intransitive transitive no pair ga arimasu.
Ee, intransitive kore atsumaru, something
gather.
Tatoeba, gakusei ga atsumarimashita.
Sorekara, transitive kore wa to collect.
Tatoeba, data wo atsumeru.
Konna tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Hai. Dewa, daisanka no saigo no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa to take
apart, dissolve, clarify, ee untie,
konna imi ga arimasu.
De, eeto, kono paato (part) nan desu keredomo,
kochira desu yo ne, kore imi wa horn no imi
ga arimasu.
Ee, sorekara, kono part, kore wa ushi, cow
desu yo ne.
Soshite this part, this part is coming from
the shape of a knife.
So cut the horn from a big cow to iu no de,
ma take apart, dissolve, no imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi no baai
hotondo wa kai desu.
Tatoeba, kaiketsu suru, kore to solve toka
settle.
Ee mondai wo kaiketsu suru.
Sorekara, rikai suru, kore wa ii desu ne,
to understand.
Kono mondai wo rikai shimasu.
Ee, sorekara, gokai suru, kore wa to misunderstand.
Ee ryoukaisuru, kore wa to give consent.
Ee, soshite, ma, eeto onyomi no kono ge nan
desu keredomo, genetsuzai, konna toki ni
dake tsukaimasu.
Kore, resolve, sorekara, nante iu desu ka,
untie nan desu keredomo, kore fever.
Dakara netsu wo sageru kusuri to iu no de,
medicine for a fever no imi desu.
Tsugi ni kunyomi nan desu keredomo, kunyomi
wa to desu.
Tatoeba, toku.
Ee kore to solve.
Kono mondai wo toite kudasai.
Sorekara, to melt to iu no de, transitive,
intransitive no pair ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, tokasu, kore wa transitive desu.
Koori wo tokasu.
Sorekara, tokeru, kore wa intransitive desu.
Koori ga tokeru.
Ee particle ni kiotsukete kudasai.